think you can recognize the movie scenes
behind some of the internet's biggest
memes well today we're going to be going
over 12 that you may not have known
about
nice we give this meme our nod of
approval it's been on the internet since
around like 2012 and it's the perfect
way to tell someone I like this but do
you know who the actor in the meme is if
you guessed Zach Galifianakis you'd be
wrong many on the internet thought it
was but this meme actually comes from
Robert Redford in the 1972 movie
Jeremiah Johnson he gives this nod to
his fictional family after catching his
first fish and it's actually meant to
serve as this sort of hey we can make it
out in the wilderness after all kind of
moment in the movie now that's one good
idea I think you've got the next great
life hack this guy does our next meme is
used whenever someone has like a great
idea uh like say can't get fired if you
don't have a job the head tapping guy is
actually actor coyote awumi portraying
the fictional role safe in the BBC three
series hashtag Hood documentary which is
sort of like a parody of urban culture
documentaries and the iconic moment came
after role safe makes one awkward double
entender about his date yeah my I think
which was beautiful because they've got
a good brain at which point he Taps his
head to really drive the point home and
while we're on the topic of awkward
conversations do you even remember the
movie This meme was based on it's been
on the internet since all the way back
to 2009 and its three panels can be
customized to make it look like the rock
is reacting to something shocking just
said like I finally caught all 151
Pokemon there are 646 Pokemon now now
these screen caps come from the 2009
movie Race to Witch Mountain where the
rock plays a taxi driver who's surprised
to find two teenagers sitting in his
back seat where'd you come from it's
kind of a forgotten movie at this point
similar to our next meme but one thing
you shouldn't forget to do is subscribe
to our Channel you know those fake
celebrity death announcements that just
seem to be made to toy with your
emotions we may wish we could say bye
Felicia to those but when they do pop up
this reaction GIF is the perfect
response but why does Denzel Washington
seem so concerned and then immediately
relieved well the GIF is from the 1998
movie Fallen and it comes from a moment
where Denzel is talking to John Goodman
about the reason they're even alive
Denzel asks and when you know when your
moment comes during this tense moment
the phone rings which prompts this
joking response from Denzel that the
internet hasn't let go of since what do
you say to someone who's been wasting
your time well if they're doing it by
being super obvious you say you don't
say but otherwise it's Bye Felicia now
this meme has appeared everywhere from
Good Morning America hi Felicia to Ryan
Seacrest's radio talk show like bye
Felicia oh bye Felicia who's that but
for those of you like Ryan who are still
wondering who the heck Felicia is she
was a particularly annoying character
from the 1995 film Friday Felicia
received this iconic dismissal from Ice
Cube's character after she got just a
little bit too close as we hinted at
before if Felicia had been saying
something we already knew we'd probably
hit her with this meme you don't say was
a response that came from Rage Comics
and you've probably already noticed the
Face's close resemblance to Nicolas Cage
but did you know that sarcasm was far
from the emotion he was going for here
the expression comes from the 1988 movie
Vampire kiss during a moment where cage
is actually mocking his secretary with
his power I couldn't think of a more
horrible job if I wanted to
and you have to do it this scene caught
the internet's attention when it was
included in a YouTube compilation of bad
acting from cage and we've been
aggressively applauding it ever since so
when Robert Redford's nod just won't cut
it you can also show your approval with
this aggressive clapping but would you
ever have guessed that one of the
internet's biggest memes actually comes
from one of the most iconic movies of
the 1940s Citizen Kane during this scene
Kane is watching his wife perform Opera
but the audience just isn't having it
falling asleep in their chairs and
everything I mean hey at least they
weren't laughing like Ray Liotta am I
right when the performance is done
there's a bit of Applause but Kane feels
the need to clap vigorously when it
starts to die down giving us this moment
we haven't forgotten since have you ever
heard a laugh you couldn't forget Ray
Liotta's laugh from Goodfellas is so
memorable that the internet actually
turned it into a meme used whenever
someone finds something especially
hilarious but there was a bit more than
that going on in the actual scene there
leota's listening to funny stories when
things suddenly start to get threatening
funny how I mean what's funny about it
leota's character thinks he's in trouble
until he realizes that Tommy is joking
although the scene Still Remains tense
enough to get this awkward laugh out of
him
it sounds about as real as George glass
is there might be a conspiracy going on
in A Very Brady sequel the same day it
hit Netflix a post appeared on Tumblr
making fun of the way that Marcia
pronounced School I've never heard of
George glass at our school but the quote
from this scene that really gained a
life of its own is the one that came
shortly afterwards actually when Marcia
gives a condescending sure Jan in
response to her sister's claim to be
dating George glass and ever since then
it's become the ultimate way to dismiss
someone you find annoying sort of
similar to the Bye Felicia meme actually
super cool
so what's the best conspiracy theory you
can come up with how about what if cats
have their own internet and it's full of
pictures of us yes we can why can't the
internet just be normal this screenshot
of Keanu Reeves looking terrified at
whatever dumb conspiracy theory the
poster just came up with is actually
from the 1989 comedy Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure this movie follows
two dumb teenagers who have to time
travel in order to finish their history
report and the reason why Keanu looks so
freaked out is actually because he's
being chased by medieval knights done
our job that's cool speaking of hosts we
wish could be normal this meme comes
from the 2014 horror movie The babadook
riffing on a moment where the mother
turns around in her car seat and asks
[Music]
[Applause]
to which her child responds only by
screaming and thus a million memes were
born from that moment this can be
customized in countless ways from
putting a cat in the place of the boy to
having the world Ask America that in the
midst of the tide pod challenge now why
can't we all just come together internet
maybe even with an epic handshake Ah
that's more like it this meme has been
around seemingly longer than the
internet with one of the earliest
examples online being one where the
handshake causes an explosion more
recent examples have the handshake
immortalized as a watercolor painting
customized by labeling them as two
opposites coming together but do you
know which two 80s action stars were
responsible for this epic handshake
that's right it's Arnold Schwarzenegger
and Carl Weathers in the 1987 movie
Predator upon meeting the two men lock
hands before proceeding to arm wrestle
to find out who's the toughest what's
the matter
the CIA got the pushing too many pencils
man some memes come from the most random
of places which of these scenes were you
most surprised to see in their original
context and are there any movie memes we
should have included here's Johnny we're
all fans of memes here so make sure to
let us know down in the comment section
foreign
[Music]